you weren't chasing Fame anymore you
were just enjoying the moment yes and it
took me some time to get there though
that takes time or you kind of uh just
want to be noticed and have attention
and things that I didn't get as a kid
and and all of a sudden you get that and
you get that and you realize it's it's
kind of just comes and goes and no one
really cares and it just doesn't Define
my life anymore because that's the thing
too I mean I know you guys are in LA but
that's what I don't love about it is the
incestuous nature of the city that every
single person pretty much is in one
industry it's like even if you're a
lawyer you're you know working for a
studio or it just everything's measured
everything's a dick measuring contest
right yeah oh I went on this audition
today I got this i got this you know
what I mean all your friends you're like
you start to really have a lot of
self-hate